في تركيا حسمت صحف محليه الانتخابات في
البلاد قبل ان تبدا طبعا والفائز بحسب هذه
الصحف هو اردوغان اما السبب الاول في فوزه
هو منافسه كمال كريجدار اوغلو فبمجرد ان
اعلنت الطاوله السداسيه للمعارضه التركيه
ترشيح زعيم حزب الشعب الجمهوري مرشحا
للانتخابات الرئاسيه اعلنت صحيفه حريه بان
الرئيس التركي اردوغان هو المستفيد الاكبر
من هذا الترشيح
ويعتبر بان اوغلو هو المنافس الوحيد اليوم
للرئيس واوضحت الصحيفه ان كلجدار اوغلو
انتصر باتفاق احزاب المعارضه على اختياره
لتمثيلهم لكن المنتصر الاكبر هو اردوغان
الذي طالما اراد منافسه اوغلو اكثر من اي
شخص اخر ولكن لماذا يعني هذا الاصرار على
منافسته وليس شخص اخر الجواب بحسب الصحافه
المواليه فهو ان المعارضه برئاسه كمال
كيتشدار اوغلو لا تستطيع مجارات حزب
العداله والتنميه لانهم لا يملكون انجازات
حقيقيه تؤهلهم للفوز في الانتخابات
المقبله كما انها اي المعارضه وعلى راسها
حزب الشعب الجمهوري هي من رفضت مقترح
اردوغان قبل سنوات حول البناء وخطط
اردوغان حول البناء الحضري الذي كان وفقا
لاعتقاد اردوغان سيخفف من اضرار الزلزال
المدمر الاخير في تركيا
زمان
الاحزاب المعارضه وزعيمها زعيم حزب الشعب
الجمهوري السيد كمال كليتجار اوغلو يقومون
بتحريض الشعب للوقوف ضدنا ووضعوا عراقيل
امام عجله النمو والتحول المدني في الماضي
والان يكررون نفس توجهاتهم